a quarterback who would very much love
to be
the focal point of the two weeks between
conference championship sunday and the
super bowl deshaun watson he has
requested a trade now
my understanding is the official magic
words were uttered monday tuesday of
last week the texans have known
for a while that this isn't working and
he would like to go somewhere else he
was reluctant to flat out say trademe
because that represents a bridge that is
crossed that he doesn't want to walk
back across uh peter just a strange
situation and it keeps getting stranger
for the texans and on top of everything
else they hired a coach that i would say
let me just throw a dart and say
87 percent of arden football fans would
say who the hell is david culley
mike you know i've covered the nfl for
all of david culley's 27 years in it and
i know who he is and i believe i met him
a couple of times early on and talked to
him
he's a i i know and i don't mean that to
to slight him or to to say that i'm not
doing my job i don't mean that at all i
just mean that
he's an assistant coach in the nfl
i have never one time until i think it
was monday or tuesday of this week ever
in my life heard of david culley being
considered for a head coaching job
i i i just never
i never heard anybody say
and and especially in these
you know kind of
racially aware times
and culturally aware times you know
obviously david culley is is
african-american
and you you basically want to
he you would want if you were if you
were looking at the list of prominent
guys in the black community who are good
candidates for the nfl and i'm not
saying he wasn't on any list i i don't i
haven't really followed all the listen
but he certainly wasn't in the
uh you know uh eric b enemy todd balls
jim caldwell leslie frazier vane and
and again
i am not saying here that the houston
texans made a bad hire i'm saying here
that the houston texans made a shocking
hire
and we'll see how the hire turns out
yeah i mean there have been shocking
hires in the past that have worked out
but the reality is david culley wasn't
on anyone else's list at all never been
a coordinator a career position coach
had a couple of years with the buffalo
bills as quarterbacks coach 2017 the
year they got back to the playoffs for
the first time in a generation 2018 the
first year with josh allen before
reverting to the receiver coach role and
assistant head coach a role that he had
with andy reid in kansas city and with
john harbaugh currently well for now for
not much longer in baltimore and 18
years with andy reid i think has
significance i i think that
that the fact that andy reid trusted him
for that long and he's been
and had been with reed for that long
you're just going to pick up
plenty of football information
information by osmosis being around andy
reid for 18 years peter
i mean no doubt about it and i have no
idea if that's if that was a major
factor if the interview was a major
factor you know these are things that
we look forward to hearing from uh cal
mcnair and nick casario about what the
major factors were in this as i say
shocking higher i think the one other
thing to consider right here
is that you know they have to know have
to know
that this is going to be or has the
potential to be the rockiest year in the
history of this franchise if they do
trade uh desean watson
uh they're going to be i believe
you know hey if i were a houston texan
season ticket holder
not only if they trade deshaun watson
would i burn my tickets
but i would show up at the first game of
the season with a picket sign and say do
not go in here and support this lousy
organization that trades 25 year old
franchise quarterbacks and they trade
them because they can't get along with
them
i mean this this whole story
is
you know beyond the pale to me it's
absolutely unacceptable
that
three months after four months after
you've paid a guy a market contract for
quarterbacks uh four months after that
uh you know he says i never want to step
foot in this building again i mean
there's something really wrong here so
my point is david culley is going to
have to bear the brunt of that
and the thing you hear about him is what
a gentleman what a great guy he is what
a patient guy is all that stuff
he's gonna have to deal with
a uh
you know he's gonna have to deal with a
storm
in and around his building and in and
around his team if they trade deshaun
watson and then on the other hand mike
maybe just maybe i doubt it but maybe he
and nick casario can sit in a room
and and and try to convince at least try
to convince deshaun watson it doesn't
seem that this will be likely try to
convince him that
you know we'd love you to stay and
here's why you should so we'll see what
the future holds
i don't think deshaun watson is going to
participate in that conversation that's
the problem because this isn't a guy
who's impulsive this isn't a guy who's
temperamental this isn't a guy who's
just flying off the handle and will
change his mind at some point in the
future based upon who they sign in free
agency or who they draft this is a guy
who took his time to get to the point
where he said please trade me
and once he crosses that point that's it
he's done
and so
the texans have multiple options at
their disposal and this next move by
them will be the most fascinating and
it's very simple they can say yes they
can say no and mean it or they can say
no and not mean it as a way to generate
maximum trade leverage the old rick
spielman we have no intent to trade
percy harvin routine and just sit back
and wait for offers to come from teams
that watson would be willing to play for
whether it's the jets the dolphins or
someone else
and and see
look
at at some point someone's going to
offer so much that it's going to be very
hard to say no because if you say no
then you still have to deal with the
mess with deshaun watson whether that
means him
staying away from the team
and not showing up or whether it means
him showing up and behaving like jaylen
ramsey did in 2019 with the jaguars
where it was this constant dark cloud
over the team of i want out i want out i
want out i don't think watson's going to
do that i don't think he's wired to do
that i think in his mind he's done and
he's out and let's be adults here i'm
not going to show up and act like
anything but a mature responsible adult
now from ramsey's perspective
he decided he wanted out while he was
already in and so
you can't hold out at that point it gets
complicated but just trust me you can't
hold out at that point for watson he's
making the decision before he ever sets
foot back in the organization
and it's easier for him to just say i'm
out i'm done i'm not going to show up
and act like my hamstring hurts and not
practice or say that i've got a headache
or a concussion and not playing a game
i'm just not showing up and if you're
going to come after me for money then
then let's do you want to get nuts let's
get nuts but i feel like that's what
watson's position is going to be if they
refuse to take whatever offers peter
they will inevitably get they can say we
don't want to trade him and they're
still going to get offers from teams to
trade him
the most interesting thing is going to
the most interesting time with this i
believe
um is going to be almost exactly three
months from now mike the draft basically
is three months from last night you know
it's the last thursday in april and so
we're going to see obviously a bunch of
activity between now and then but the i
would say that there's basically like a
three-month deadline
um you know the deadline is three months
down the road and and i think there will
be a lot of activity but i also think if
you're the texans
the last thing i would do right now if
you're the texans is to say all right
we've reached this impasse
uh let's trade him right away
both for
uh reasons you wouldn't get your best
offer that way and to see if just to see
if the waters can be calmed it looks as
though they can't be calmed but you know
if you are talking about trading
potentially
the best player he and jj watt the best
two players in the history of this
franchise
i think you better be deliberate
and exercise all do caution
and peter this creates an interesting
angle to it because i agree with you the
texans from their perspective should
wait right up until the draft because
then when you do it you get back
draft picks you can use
right now to help make your team better
but the problem is by waiting three
months there may be some suitors for
deshaun watson who have moved on to
other quarterback options because of
this potentially robust free agent and
trade market once you get your
quarterback situation figured out you're
out of the deshaun watson discussion it
actually helps a team like the jets that
would presumably only be trading
draft assets for it to wait until late
april the dolphins for example like what
do you do with tua well it's easier to
figure out what you're going to do with
tua if you get deshaun watson on march
17. if you get to sean watson the night
before the draft starts then you got to
figure out what the hell are we doing
with tua so assuming
mike who was a part of the tool would be
a part of any deal with miami wouldn't
he
don't want him what if they don't want
him well so i'm saying well then they're
not going to make a trade with miami
i don't then they wouldn't make a trade
with miami it's the same thing with the
jets you know uh
why not if you make a trade with the
jets you take the second pick in the
draft and you take sam darnold and you
take other other picks
and
if you do that if you do that then you
get darnold and maybe you get either
justin fields or
whoever whoever it is but in my opinion
there are teams
that you would get their quarterback
back in addition to draft capital and so
i don't think there's any trade with
miami unless part of the trade is uh
is uh uh
you know it's two with tiger veloa
well peter i also think there's a
possibility of a three-team trade we may
have talked about this before the idea
that maybe there's another team out
there that wants to us so whatever they
give up to get to a flows through the
dolphins and then over to the texans
because it may be the texans just maybe
they want to start over with a rookie
maybe they have someone else in mind
that they want to bring to town maybe
they'd love to have derrick carr of all
guys because he's david's brother and
they want to get back to their their
franchise roots but it could be
that you don't want that guy that the
team that wants watson is willing to
send you so you find some way to make it
happen and and uh i i think it's going
to get potentially convoluted and
potentially complicated if it's
something the texans want to do which
also means that you do need to take some
time to plan it out the right way if you
are nick casario but yeah nick casario i
don't know that he bargained for this
when he took the job although he knew or
should have known that desean watson
wasn't happy and for david culley i mean
he's 65 he's never been mentioned as a
potential nfl head coach it's no matter
how dysfunctional it is
it's still an nfl head coaching job and
that window is otherwise not going to
open for david culley he's got to jump
through it and be happy about it and any
problem that he has is a good problem
because he's facing the problems
inherent to being an nfl head coach
which means he is an nfl head coach
what you said about nick casario there
is absolutely right nick casario i
believe
you know if i'm sure and i'm sure he has
done this or will do this he's got to
make a list in order of the x number of
quarterbacks let's say eight
quarterbacks in the nfl who are
available okay and or who might be
available you know and we're talking
about sam darnold tuatanga veloa jared
goff matthew stafford you know when you
make this list and you go all the way
down to let's say jacoby bursett or or
whatever and you have to make a decision
uh i mean there's mitchell trubisky and
i mean who knows somebody's gonna sign
mitchell trubisky and give him a chance
i'd be shocked if he goes back to the
bears
but but and and i really think that what
you're going to see here
is a very
bella chicken approach a very clinical
approach to this
by nick casario and by the texans in
which they would say okay we've got
the titanic on our hands we've got this
sinking ship and somehow somehow we've
got to keep bailing put the lifeboats
out and figure out how we're going to go
forward in 2021 without our franchise
quarterback and so you make your list
and you see you you call the lions and
if you love matthew stafford and you say
hey um what
what can we do potentially you know
revolving around matthew stafford and it
could be a three-way deal mike you're
absolutely right you could be trading
watson somewhere else and then using
part of the draft capital to go get uh
you know to go get matthew stafford
that's why this is going to be a mayhem
like story especially for the next
say six to seven weeks before the start
of free agency
coupled with the fact mike coupled with
the fact
that
i'm told that it's very likely the nfl
is going to have similar rules in free
agency this year where visits are either
severely restricted or totally cut off
you know because the pandemic is still
here so
you know you're going to be committing
to a quarterback after talking to him on
zoom
you know and it's you know so there's a
lot of things that teams have gotten
used to and i think recruiting your
quarterback for the next 10 years
might be one of them this year
you know i had a moment when you were
talking about casario and how he will
engage in a bella chicken type analysis
that i thought of the story of thomas de
mitroff
ten years ago calling belichick
regarding his advice on a potential
trade-up to get julio jones and bella
julio jones
yeah and i i i could imagine caserio
making a call to belichick about a
potential plot for a desean watson trade
and have you seen the gif of where
belichick takes the phone and slams it
against the that's bad
if casario calls now with that request
belichick is going to hang up and or
throw the phone into the bench area at
the sideline um one thing that i want to
point out to folks because
i've noticed on social media and people
have just kind of suggested that it's a
given that desean watson's camp leaked
that he's asked for a trade in the
immediate aftermath of this david culley
news to reign on the parade and just
kind of throw a wrench into what should
be a good day and a positive day for the
texans here's what happened
what happened is word gets out that
david culley is getting the job so then
reporters start circling back to
watson's camp to say hey does this make
a difference they were together at the
pro bowl aaron wilson of the houston
chronicle reported they made a good
connection cully and and deshawn watson
last year when the ravens coaching staff
was there does this matter and through
that due diligence that's where it
became known that watson had already
requested a trade so it doesn't matter
so i don't think this was diabolical or
sinister or in any way malevolent by
desean watson's camp to give the texans
a rough time the texans should have
known through the application of
foresight as you flick that david cully
domino
you're eventually going to dredge up the
news that you know that no one else had
known that deshaun watson had officially
said trade me
41 years in this business mike and i've
gotten used to
people on the outside jumping to
conclusions
after i've reported something or some oh
it came from here
and maybe sometimes it did
but you know people on the outside who
jump to conclusions
uh don't know for sure where it came
from and in my opinion if they want to
speculate and have fun on twitter that's
fine
but reporting it is fact is is another
thing and most often i have found
that what is reported in those cases
is crapola
but these were people on the inside on
twitter not on the inside per se but in
the business who were just assuming that
this was desean watson and his
representatives deciding to
uh
you know what they say about the word
graphic phrase just rain on the on the
parade
oh i know what they say about it i know
i know very well i have been there and
done that many times okay uh back to
colley though because i i think he
deserves his moment
because this is a culmination of a long
career in the nfl and peter i when sims
and i were trying to digest all this
yesterday you know it occurred to me
that maybe he's never been a candidate
to be a head coach because he's not one
of these guys that is constantly working
all the angles and using his agent to
plant his name and calling up guys like
us saying hey have you ever thought
about david culley as a potential head
coaching candidate look at what he's
accomplished over the course of his
career look at how he gets along with
players i think that colley may just be
one of these guys who's kept his head
low and his mouth shut and he just does
his job and
in an industry where there are plenty of
people who are constantly looking to
find a way to position themselves and
promote themselves to be head coaches
you're at a disadvantage if you don't
behave that way
mike you know i'll make this point about
that theory okay
and
and most of the time like for instance
let's take arthur smith
okay like
i i think arthur smith is one heck of a
candidate
a say in the last 12 months because i
watched the tennessee titans play
football
i watched the quarterback ryan tannehill
who had a guru in miami uh you know in
adam gase for a while but the guru never
i mean obviously tannehill was hurt a
lot but he never had him play half as
well as he played as he's played in
tennessee so then you say hmm that's one
in arthur smith's column here's the
other one in arthur smith's column watch
some of his play calls and watch how
you know he he basically
pounds you pounds you pounds you with
derrick henry and then all of a sudden
you get to the one yard line everybody
converges on derrick henry and and ryan
tannehill takes a shotgun snap and just
prances into the end zone untouched
he's an intelligent guy who does smart
things in games and smart things with
his players
and with players who are you know the
khalif raymonds of the world who went to
holy cross or wherever and he makes
players out of them and i'm not saying
he makes play but i mean he coaches him
up he puts them in position and all i'm
saying mike is that
i really think
yes can agents
get coaches in front of teams
yes
can agents get coaches jobs
technically i guess so if you say well
he got him in front of a team look i
don't even know who brandon staley's uh
agent is i i don't know
but brandon staley got the job with the
chargers because in two interviews
they raced to to get him signed so he
wouldn't go take an interview with the
eagles
and and look i can tell you the rams
absolutely unequivocally
you know they were trying to hide
brandon staley this year but his team
performed so great
you know he takes over for wade phillips
a coaching legend he's got the number
one defense in football jaylen ramsey is
like worshiping at his altar this 37
year old coordinator now 38 all i'm
saying is in my opinion
most guys don't they might be able to
get help by their agents they're not
getting jobs because of their agents
well and kali wasn't in a position to
showcase himself at all which makes the
move to use the word that you utilized
earlier in the segment shocking that he
ends up becoming the head coach of the
team and there is a theory
rocketing around out there that kali is
going to have the job for a few years
and then josh mccown will elevate to the
head coaching job now the fact that pep
hamilton is going to be the quarterbacks
coach and not mccown throws a wrench
into that theory but there is a belief
that mccown is going to some way somehow
be part of this coaching staff when the
dust settles unless the brouhaha from
last week when he got a head coaching
interview has caused the organization to
say let's just wait a little while on
bringing josh mccown into the fold
officially maybe we'll sign him again
next year to actually be a player so
peter the the dust settles or at least
begins to settle on this year's
quarterback carousel
um two minority hires
robert sala and david culley eric b
enemy
shutout again and you and i have talked
about in the past and i don't know what
more there is to say eric banned me
should be an nfl head coach and i'm
still working on this theory that the
billionaires don't like to be told what
to do by anyone so the more that people
like us and fans and others in the media
are saying hire eric the enemy maybe
some of them are just saying no we'll do
what we want don't you tell us what to
do that's the only thing i can think of
at this point
i think let's talk about houston for a
minute
you know nick casario has been in this
role with bill belichick for i think 12
years
uh or or some you know at least a decade
uh you know he took over the the sort of
uh
you know the chief assistant to
belichick and personnel
after scott pioli went to kansas city
and so he's been there a long time and
he has been thinking for a long time
okay who am i gonna hire as a coach
who's my shirtless as a coach and again
i have no idea how he ended up with
david culley but he's thinking about
that
and i can tell you
that nick casario i'm sure is mindful of
what is going on in the outside world
but he is not going to let troy vincent
or anybody
tell him who to hire for a head coach
and i'm not saying that troy vincent
called him and said hire this guy i
don't because i don't think he did
but all i'm saying is he's not going to
be told who to hire for a head coach
this is his shot and for whatever reason
which i hope will find out soon he
picked uh david culley and we'll see why
but
that is one of the fallacies in this in
my opinion cal mcnair is saying
you know i come to me when you get the
guy who you want you know and we'll talk
about it but cal mcnair is not out there
uh you know mining or
you know going out looking for all of
the candidates that's why he's got
nicerio there well and the one name that
we have yet to mention 31 minutes into
the program jackie used to be i think
that the cully hire is all part of his
broad master 10 15 20-year plan to
basically be the surrogate owner of the
texans without the owner realizing that
he's usurped control because there are
people who believe kali is just a
short-term bridge to the guy that easter
bee would have hired right now if he
could in joshua count so we'll see how
that plays
out hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports